la région de chaudière appalaches c'est
ici que se concentre la moitié de la
production porcine au québec simon
breton produit habituellement 6000 port
par annie en visitant sa maternité
il se demande ce qu'il adviendra de
secours se l'est puisque à quelques
mètres de là des ports attendent dans un
enclos leur tour à l'abattoir ce que
vous voyez là il ya des parcs champêtre
l'abattoir mais quand peut pas renvoyer
creux et plus le temps passe plus il
craint de devoir les euthanasies le
nombre de bêtes qui se rendent à
l'abattoir diminue de semaine en semaine
actuellement j'avais le droit de
n'envoyer seulement 35 cas du chômage
avait le droit d'envoyer environ 110 les
cas de coved 19 chez les employés et la
mise en place de mesures de
distanciation physique limite la
capacité des abattoirs olymel par
exemple a dû fermer ses installations de
yamachiche pendant deux semaines la
production a repris
mélusine est loin de retour à la normale
sa capacité d'abattage est réduite de
85%
résultat les ports restent à la ferme ce
qu'on n'a pas le choix de faire c'est de
créer de l'entente parce qu'on n'est pas
capable d envoyer à l'abattoir donc on
doit les garder chez nous jusqu'à
maintenant les producteurs sont parvenus
à gérer cette baisse de production dans
les abattoirs
mais il ne pourrait peut-être pas faire
face à une autre fermeture
ça serait très problématique on parle de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
tableaux qui devrait être euthanasié
fait que personne n'a choisi le député
de beauce et critique en matière
d'agriculture rappelle que les éleveurs
étaient déjà sur la corde raide avant la
pandémie c'est une année très très
difficile
le blocus a faim de contes avec la chine
et qui venait d'être levée il n'y a pas
eu besoin d'être levé longtemps que tout
est arrêté avec toute la question du
chronobus
mais cette année nous aurons dans le
port avec à ce qu'on veut vraiment chaud
que l'air depuis janvier le prix du porc
a perdu 25% de sa valeur sur les marchés
et pour l'instant les prévisions ne
laisse pas entrevoir des jours meilleurs
ici les lire et gamache radio-canada
saint-elzéar en beauce